l'essai est à nouveau transformée pour
le tournoi c'est de coeur la sixième
édition a permis d'engranger cette année
soixante mille euros au profit de six
associations des dons récoltés par les
équipes
chaque année on progresse chaque année
on optimise un peu la structure est
hélas on arrive à un équilibre global
qui est vraiment intéressant avec du
rugby à 7 masculin du rugby à sept
féminin du rugby à 5 le dimanche est un
tournoi de dodgeball de balle au
prisonnier le samedi après midi
chaque événement sportif du tournoi
permettant d'augmenter le montant
reversé à une association au final un
tournoi amical mais de haut niveau entre
fédéral une et pro d2 pour les équipes
masculines les 10 et 11 juin 26 équipes
ont foulé les terrains bas pour sûr elle
c'est important parce que déjà c'est la
fin de saison ça permet de préparer la
saison d'après et après on est on est
heureux ici pour donner de l'argent aux
associations à travers notre
participation le premier objectif c'est
de participer et contribuer au bonheur
des contribuer au bonheur des
associations bien sûr mais après on est
des compétitrices et nous on veut gagner
parmi les bénévoles des grands noms du
rugby comme sofiane guitoune
international français c'est un rôle
important c'est un rôle qu'on qu'on se
doit de jouer parce que ben si on peut
donner un coup de main bénévolement
gratuitement donner un coup de pouce à
des assauts ce c
voilà c'est tout à notre honneur et je
pense moi je suis je suis partisan de ça
donc je le fais avec grand plaisir
près de 4000 personnes ont participé au
tournoi depuis sa création le 7 de coeur
a récolté près de 250000 euros